tim mcgraw is best known as country
music legend now he's starring in a tv
drama set in the old west it's called
1883. it's a prequel to the hit show
yellowstone tells the origin original
story of the dutton family and follows
their journey to the west back in 1883.
the show premieres this sunday on the
viacom cbs streaming platform paramount
plus mcgraw and his lovely wife that's
faith hill play a married couple james
and margaret dutton so in the scene they
check into a hotel before beginning
their journey out west here's a peek
how much did you spend on this room
well this last room we'll see for a
while
you deserve it
[Music]
a bath i imagine that
i wonder if there's hot water in the
lobby where's the water
i read about a hotel in new york and
they pipe hot water straight into the
room
turn the faucet on and it comes right
out
can you imagine that
well for now you got to imagine me
hauling buckets of water up on stairs
yeah what happens when you get some
buckets of water upstairs tim mcgraw
joins us now from guthrie texas where
he's on the 1883 set he's getting ready
for another day of filming i'm told tim
thank you first tim i have to say
apologize i got egg all over my face if
you could see me in person because in
the meeting yesterday they said tim
mcgraw is coming on he's just going to
take a break from the set he's going to
be in his costume and during the break
i'm told you said to the producer
actually this isn't a costume this is me
so please please please please bear with
me these are my clothes i don't think
they had these clothes in 1883.
i know it says on all of our people i
know i know i thought that was pretty
fast before the 1800s yeah i was like
tim reminds me of the time i was walking
on the street and somebody came up to me
and said aren't you gail king and i said
yeah and she said are you in disguise i
go nope this is my face
so please i'm so so sorry but let's talk
about you tim mcgraw in 1883 because
what happens in that scene after you and
faith have a lovely bath scene i'll talk
about that a little bit later on but i'm
thinking this must be such a fun role to
play i saw you on the horse i saw you i
saw you kicking butt i saw you taking
charge is this a fun role for you to
play
oh it's a dream you know i i grew up in
louisiana riding horses my whole life um
i've got gotten away from it for a while
but it was fun to get back into it and
get back on a horse and and we've done
some pretty crazy things on horses it's
been it's been quite an adventure for
sure but i i mean it's every kid's dream
to be able to play a role like this i
mean
to to be out on a horse and and you know
shooting bad guys i mean it's been it's
been quite quite an adventure we've
really enjoyed it
and it's also got to be a dream if your
wife is faith hill number one you and
faith are terrific on and off screen
together but i love that bathroom scene
the tub scene i really like it because
it's sensual it's intimate it's tasteful
it's really very tender and loving so
i'm wondering when you play something
like that and you're looking into the
eyes do you see margaret dutton or do
you see faith hill this is my wife
well
well it it took a bit to get to to see
margaret and not faith i mean it was you
know it's uh
it was interesting to do that scene
together because uh we felt like we were
giving up a little bit of part of our
life but um once we realized that we
were in character and sort of just fell
into character and and speaking our
lines it it became pretty natural
as as margaret and james so it worked
out pretty well but um we were glad it
was over i can tell you that
congratulations on what i did i did but
i did like the rehearsal
yeah oh yeah
lots of rehearsal
tim mcgraw you had all the right moves
just saying you had all the right moves
tim let's talk about you on set because
uh uh what i hear is word around town is
you used to sing on the sets of the
shows that you were on are you still
belting out a tune there in guthrie
texas
yeah i mean i can't help it you know
somebody says something that reminds me
of a song so i start singing i'm sure
they're pretty tired of it by now but
you know there's got to be a little
levity on set because everything's so
dramatic on this show and um
there's there's a lot of a lot of heavy
stuff going on so you know every every
chance i get to sort of lighten it up a
bit i try to
tim i want to get back to that chemistry
with you and your wife not not about the
tub scene um but you celebrated 25 years
of marriage yeah so for all of those um
that are in relationships that are
married what advice do you give them
oh my
say yes ma'am a lot
that's the best advice that i can give
because i you know i have a wife and
three daughters
so i don't i don't get too many words in
so yes ma'am probably the best thing
that i can say but you know really and
truly
it's it's a commitment and um we decided
early on that that uh we're not going to
give up and and we want we want our life
together and we want to raise our kids
together and and it's too easy to bail
out and we we're never going to do that
yeah somebody told me once you know my
parents
didn't fight they fought but they didn't
fight through and sometimes you got to
fight through i've never forgotten that
but you and faith are empty nesters what
is that like your three lovely daughters
are they're grown up they're confident
20-something all very very very very
poised and really lovely people what's
that been like for you guys
it's it's been incredible to watch them
grow up and yeah become the young women
they've become i mean they're they're
really strong-willed confident young
women we have a 24 year old a 23 year
old and a 20 year old so no teenagers
anymore so it's a it's pretty
interesting to to be in that world now
as parents but uh we're just so proud of
them because they're just such great
young women and
and they're confident and they're sweet
and they're they're very caring about
other people and you know what what
better could you ask for
with your daughters
let me just say your kids don't get that
way by themselves so kudos to you in
faith and congratulations to you in
faith 25 years i bet your daughters are
just as proud of you mom and dad
together on screen for the first time i
like it it's a good look tim mcgraw
thank you tell faith we said hey
bye thank you
i will thank you guys bye-bye see ya
1883 premieres this sunday on the viacom
cbs streaming service paramount plus
we'll be right back